une ferme un conteneur maritime deux
choses qui ne devait pas se rencontrer
et pourtant c'est le pari fou de la
société indépendante living buzz
elle vient d'inaugurer son fou de
conteneurs complètement autonome des
fruits et légumes doivent 6 pouces et 7
à sartrouville en bord de seine que ce
drôle de concept a pris place alors
c'est très simple dans ce container il
ya comme des jardinières avec de la
terre ce qu'on appelle de la terre hors
sol donc de la terre normal mélange avec
du compost
les plantes sont ont leurs racines qui
prennent pied danser jardinières elles
sont arrosés par de l'eau de pluie que
nous récupérons stock on filtre on est
éclairé par des led qui elle ne s'appuie
que sur de la lumière produite par des
panneaux solaires photovoltaïques
implantés en toiture du foot containers
se fout de contes narrés pour le moment
en phase d'expérimentation et ce pendant
un an soit 4 saisons ce qui permettra de
tester le système
quelles que soient les conditions météo
l'objectif c'est de démontrer qu'il est
bien possible de créer un nouveau
système de production agricole
utilisable pour tous ceux qui vivent en
autonomie en autonomie ce sont les
réfugiés dans les camps de réfugiés qui
n'ont aujourd'hui aucune possibilité de
subvenir à leurs besoins alimentaires
dans des conditions normales ce sont ce
les scientifiques qui vivent base vie
autonome nok avec ce type de système on
a la possibilité qui est mobile on a
apprécié des de produire proche du lieu
de consommation et c'est ça qui est
essentiel pour gérer cette
expérimentation in dépendant klingbeil à
embaucher mourad washi responsable du
prototype
pendant toute cette année est installé
dans un mobile home il veillera 24
heures sur 24 et 7 jours sur 7 sur le
fou de conteneurs j'habite sur la base
indépendant living bays depuis le 3 août
2020 tous les jours je m'occupe de faire
tourner cette base et je m'occupe aussi
tout simplement de faire pousser toutes
ces plantes de suivre leur évolution et
de vérifier leur état de santé et
pour poursuivre jusqu'à la récolte une
vingtaine de variétés de fruits et de
légumes pousseront donc pendant un an
dans cette ferme
insolite une manière de déterminer si le
foot conteneurs autonome pourra devenir
un nouveau système agricole